i want to talk a second about uh
something that you wrote in your book
and that i firmly believe is true
why women with violent tendencies must
be avoided all right it's one of your
red flags number seven yeah yeah and you
wrote this book before this trial even
took place right it was back in 2020
uh i think that the book came out and
one of your red flags page 59 i got your
book right here and i'm this is not a
promo or anything by the way uh
you you have that women have violent
tendencies are a massive red flag and
the word massive is in bold of all the
red flags in this uh chapter
there's more bold in this section about
avoiding
violent women than any other red flag
you've bolded i haven't made my point
clear enough avoided all violent women
bold at all cost exclamation point i'm
here to underscore that to anybody
watching this it never ends well
uh if somebody gets violent it's not
going to end well for you you're going
to end up in a bad situation
best case scenario i've seen it's a
domestic violence claim worst case
scenario it's a criminal action
aggravated assault assault and battery
assault you don't want to be on the
wrong end of either of those two so
um
when it comes to violent women sorry to
jump in but when it comes to you know
violent women as it comes up in trials
or any family law issues that you've
dealt with
is it is it just showing up during the
marriage or are there examples of it
leading up to the marriage in your
experience from what you've heard with
couples that you deal with with divorces
yeah i mean it's both
sometimes people will look past it if if
a guy has one itis and the woman has
mental health issues and she's got a lot
of anger issues and she thinks it's okay
to
you know hit
someone else same-sex marriages too men
and women uh
yeah i i agree with uh what you just
posted it it's zero wiggle room
because
it only gets worse and the more it's
done the more entitled feel just walk
away uh if you're not living together it
should be easy block them
get away from people who are violent
it's not going to end well
is there a way to establish somebody's
violent history by doing some kind of a
public record search on them maybe they
were
like let's say you're in your 40s okay
and you're dating somebody that's
close to your age maybe a little bit
younger they've obviously dated for a
while they may have been married
previously they've probably had a
relationship or two is there a a public
record database that you could search
for for any charges of like criminal
violence domestic violence anything like
that that would give a guy an
opportunity to say that's it i'm out you
know like you know they get the facts
front and center before she even says
anything
yeah it depends upon the jurisdiction or
is that misogyny now
well it depends upon the jurisdiction i
was involved in a domestic violence case
where
uh the guy
i'm representing the guy the woman
claimed that he assaulted her physically
assaulted her
so he actually just googled her and she
saw that she had a domestic violence
claim against a professional athlete
five years earlier that was denied that
was dismissed
so with prejudice she couldn't refile it
in that jurisdiction so
we discussed it and
so he just did a simple google search
some jurisdictions do have those kind of
cases if you know her birthday
and you know her exact first and last
name you could look and see
in many jurisdictions look up the
dockets in that state if you know where
she's lived so those are registered at
the state level not the federal level
yeah yeah these are all state state laws
uh it might be a little bit more
difficult to get a domestic violence
claim uh that they've uh that they filed
but not impossible so i would definitely
take a look at that if somebody tells
you look my boyfriend i had him like
incarcerated he put his hands on me
uh you know you want to just proceed
with extreme caution because as we're
going to talk about it's very easy for
somebody to go in and make a claim you
know on a domestic violence case uh and
get a temporary order uh it's too easy
in a lot of jurisdictions so is it
is it equally easy for men and women or
is it just women that it's easy for
uh it's equally easy for men and women
i'd say 90 of the cases that i've seen
and been involved with uh when you first
go in it's an ex parte hearing with the
judge ex parte meaning the other side's
not there and then you will tell the
judge who's on duty
uh that day
you know what happened and whether and
i'd say 90 percent or more of the times
they get a temporary restraining order
or a temporary protection from abuse
order and then within 10 days in
pennsylvania's 10 days or 20 days in
some jurisdictions there has to be a
final hearing where there has to be a
disposition of is this real or not and
um
but in the meantime you can you're
kicked out of your house as soon as they
serve you you don't you're not allowed
to have contact with the person who
filed it even through third parties so i
tell anybody who comes to me who's been
served
get off of social media if they try to
contact you no way block them because
you're going to set yourself up for an
indirect criminal contempt charge if
your girlfriend or ex-wife or soon-to-be
ex-wife
feels sorry and said ah the kids miss
you we want you to come back
no way until that is withdrawn and the
judge signs withdrawal form or else they
could change their mind and tell the
police look he violated this temporary
restraining order or temporary
protection from abuse i've seen that
happen where these people are so twisted
they know
how to get you in more trouble you don't
want that so
that's
universal advice if somebody files
something like that against you
no contact until the case is resolved
because you're going to set yourself up
for a world of hurt before you carry on
to the next point let me just tell you
guys in the ticker below here um and if
you're listening to it on a podcast it's
entrepreneurs in cars.com forward slash
red dash flags you don't need to buy my
book to get the chapter on red flags you
can get it for free just by opting into
my email list so if you want to grab it
if you haven't seen it it's there and
it's available to you for free uh it's
got uh red flag number seven which talks
about violence and you know the other 19
obviously which are the other ones you
want to pay attention to when it comes
to dealing with women on a long term
basis right on hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you